okay remember that if you are someone
who does any shopping on amazon.com we
are now getting into the holiday buying
season if you were buying gifts for feet
for people the shopping you already plan
to do can support us if you go to david
pakman.com slash amazon before shopping
interesting item Pat purchased through
our link over the last week the original
Ghostbusters film from 1984 uh I know
that there's a new Ghostbusters I have
not seen it it did not look particularly
good question have you seen the new
Ghostbusters and have you seen the old
ghostbusters I have seen the old dust
Ghostbusters that a must uh the new one
I heard everyone was coming out against
it initially yeah but it actually got
some pretty good rating so I may have to
check it out I remember I don't know if
it was was that was it filming here in
Boston or New York I remember either
when i was living in new york or maybe
since moving to Boston people were like
oh Ghostbusters is filming in some
neighborhood but I don't remember if it
was here there maybe both maybe you were
on vacation in Italy maybe it was in
Italy and they were actually filming in
Italy yeah I don't know okay so yeah
Ghostbusters love Ghostbusters from 1984
most expensive item ordered this week
through our amazon link is the vitamix
professional series 500 blender that is
a serious blender i don't know if you've
heard of these Vitamix blenders but it
is intense that's the upper echelon a
blender that's far ahead of the magic
bullets and everything else no doubt
about it remember if you ever shop on
amazon.com david pakman.com slash amazon
nothing will look different it'll just
redirect you to the amazon website but
then through the magic of the internet
anything you buy we get a little
kickback from somewhere in the range of
seven to eight percent